yo
somebody come try this cousin you're
right that was that perfect hey go chef
recently i spent almost an entire day
thinking about this place this fictional
restaurant in chicago and the people in
it would marcus get the recognition he
deserved for his baked goods or give up
what would become of sydney's
aspirations and talents would richie
crash and burn and would carmi who was
trying his best to hold this place
together learn how to cope with the
death of his brother
and what would happen to the restroom i
kept thinking about this place in these
people as i was going about my day
because that morning i had just watched
episode 7 of the bear an episode that
brought the season's boiling tensions to
a head
we're firing 76 beasts 34 chickens okay
the bear snuck up on me it's an
unpretentious unassuming show about a
few people working in a kitchen in
chicago trying to make ends meet and yet
it packs a lot of punch into a small
space
let's take a look at what makes it so
intense and more importantly why we care
this video is sponsored by mubi
from the moment you enter the mouth of
the bear formed by the structure of this
bridge you're thrown into the intense
world of a restaurant kitchen it's been
over a decade since i worked a food
service job but it's a uniquely intense
environment and the bear captures that
intensity incredibly well let's take a
look at one 55 second segment and see
how the bear creates this intensity
without descending into confusion for
the audience chefs we got to sharpen our
knives when we get a sack we got to
sharpen your brain when we get a second
you've been here for two weeks we've
been having money problems for two weeks
one plus one equals you're an a buck i'm
calling me bobby flay sydney you stir
that pot for me please chefs you want a
cartoon please thank you
what's our best day here five okay
ibrahim give me a pot for the jordan air
so if we do six that will get us through
the week right so ball breakers just
make it easy and make the in spaghetti
say spaghetti all these knives are dull
yeti was the biggest silicone that she
was straight up by straight up done now
chef behind me yeah but why because in
11 madison park head over here he
couldn't figure it out housekeeping
shots again what the [ __ ] are you saying
anyone understand what he's saying
housekeeping means you have to clean
your stations because this place is
[ __ ] gross i refer to everybody as
chef because it's a sign of respect and
i never said i couldn't figure out the
spaghetti i said it doesn't make any
sense on this menu so it is done
the end there are a lot of elements that
go into making this moment feel intense
some are more obvious than others
there's the background music dropping
that away already makes the scene more
mellow you've been here for two weeks
we've been having money problems for two
weeks there's also the intensity of the
actors performances and the fast editing
but there are two elements that i want
to examine specifically the
cinematography and the way conflict is
layered throughout the scene let's look
at the cinematography first look at the
compositions throughout this moment the
important thing is that it feels chaotic
but in actuality it's fairly precise
shots are usually dirtied by foreground
elements or movement but it's not random
noise or shakiness and these messier
elements usually frame a single easily
identifiable subject the scene is
structured almost entirely in close-up
which gives the whole environment a
cramped feeling but which also keeps you
inside the action as if you're observing
everything as one of the members of the
kitchen we never get to step back
visually for a breath into a clean
medium or wide shot as the audience
while all this is happening the
characters or at least a few of them at
this stage also have to remain focused
on the actual food prep so that's where
our attention is directed as well and
hang on a second that's an actual veggie
stuck to carmy's knife in the middle of
all this chaos which means he's actually
chopping vegetables down there wait
you're telling me that there were no
hand models for this entire show so all
of these insert shots are actually the
actors
but where this section and i think the
show really shines is the way it builds
conflict by layering a bunch of problems
on top of each other we're immediately
confronted with a problem the dull
knives
chefs we gotta sharpen our knives when
we get a sack we gotta sharpen your
brain when we get a second
then very quickly we get a second
problem the lack of money that's being
made by the restaurant you've been here
for two weeks we've been having money
problems for two weeks this problem is
the central problem of the scene and the
whole show this is the problem that
generates the conflict in the scene the
problem is converted into conflict
because richie and carmi each think
there is a different solution to this
problem
now watch how every practical
sub-problem in the scene relates back to
that central conflict in some way richie
thinks the problem is the way karmi runs
the kitchen one plus one equals you're
an a carmi says don't call me bobby he
wants him to call him chef
because he thinks the solution to the
problem is changing the way the kitchen
is run if sydney you stir that pot for
me please chef sydney asks if carmi
wants a cartoon
and richie's confusion about this is
directly related to what he thinks the
problem is
again the way karmi is trying to run
things they go back to arguing about how
to fix the money problem
and a new problem arises carmy's need
for a pot okay
which he doesn't have because the way
the kitchen is being run so if we do six
that will get us through the week right
so ball breakers just make it easy
richie then suggests spaghetti as a
solution to the money problems
but the problem of doll knives was never
solved and carmine takes action to try
to resolve this while the characters
keep arguing about spaghetti which carmi
doesn't want to make because it doesn't
fit with the way he wants to run the
kitchen
then carmi raises another issue the lack
of cleanliness in the environment
and the way he goes about this triggers
richie again again what the [ __ ] are you
saying anyone understand what he's
saying housekeeping means you have to
clean your stations because this place
is [ __ ] gross and while this argument
continues we watch sydney make the
cartouche and the scene ends on carmy's
explanation for why he doesn't want to
make the spaghetti
this 55-second segment illustrates the
way the show creates intensity by
throwing a series of interlocking and
stacking problems at us like you'd
experience in a real kitchen but you're
able to follow the thread and you're not
confused because all of these smaller
problems help illustrate the central
conflict of the scene which is in turn
fueled by the central problem of the
show and the conflict is created not
arbitrarily but by differences in how
the characters want to solve the problem
differences which are motivated by each
character's development and overall arc
in the show so in this way little
actions like grabbing a fresh knife or
making a cartouche add to the visual
intensity of the scene but are
ultimately related to the central
conflict of the show and this is just 55
seconds this kind of thing continues
throughout most of this episode and most
of the episodes in the show
if you've seen the show and i mentioned
long take the 17 minute take that
comprises most of episode 7 probably
comes to mind but did you notice the
long takes that came before that
one of my favorite long takes from the
show was actually this one an unassuming
shot that holds for three minutes as
richie takes a call from his wife and
talks to his daughter she crying again
what'd you say
it's a humanizing moment for richie
who's been an unhinged jerk so far
throughout the show and it's the first
time sydney is seeing him in a
vulnerable position holding here on this
moment instead of cutting draws us into
the intimacy of the moment and puts us
in the slightly voyeuristic position
sydney's in
because there's no cut sydney's presence
listening in somehow feels more palpable
throughout the scene
the show uses these longish takes fairly
often when it breaks away from the
intensity of the kitchen and finds our
characters in a more vulnerable place
there's one when cicero is telling carmi
about his father there's one when richie
apologizes to his wife and a big one
when carmi finally opens up at al anon
about his brother using long takes for
these moments really creates a strong
contrast between them and the intensity
of the conflict in the kitchen in these
examples it's not really the length of
the take but the choice not to cut that
creates the effect
one example of why not cutting can make
such a difference is in this shot where
tina is struggling with a new mashed
potatoes recipe she burns this sauce
carries it to the sink when she comes
back there's another sauce prepped by
sydney already ready to go
not cutting here preserves the sense of
the passage of time in this moment which
is crucial because the audience needs to
feel like tina just how quickly and
effortlessly sydney saved the day it's a
moment that's an important part of the
arc for tina coming to respect sydney
and if you cut here and made the amount
of time that it took sydney to replace
tina's ruined sauce ambiguous you
suddenly lose an important part of that
scene and tina's arc as a character what
i love about the use of these long takes
and this applies to the stunning long
take in episode 7 is that they don't
feel showy or forced they're deployed in
moments that make sense when i was
watching episode 7 it took half the
episode before i even realized what was
happening because i was invested in the
characters and the scene not in the
filmmaking
other shows have pulled off more
technically impressive single take
episodes but this one to me never feels
forced or gimmicky it feels perfectly in
place for what the story needs to convey
and in my opinion that wins out over
technical prowess any day
which brings me to the point i want to
close on because what impressed me most
about the bear was not all the technical
proficiency when it comes to
cinematography or editing those things
are definitely there but i didn't even
notice them really the first time i was
watching the show because i was caught
up in the interpersonal conflict and
drama you can create all the intensity
you want through sound design editing
and camera work but if the audience
doesn't care about what's happening to
the characters it's not going to feel
intense you won't be invested in whether
the characters will pull it together
because you don't care about them
the reason episode 7 feels so intense
isn't really because of the long take
it's because in that episode so many
different points of conflict that have
been clearly developed throughout the
show suddenly come to a head all at once
tina bringing her son to the kitchen
creates conflict but it isn't just a
random plot point to create intensity
and conflict in this scene it's the
culmination of her character arc
revealing that she now sees this kitchen
as a place where she and her son can
learn valuable skills
earlier in the season we became invested
in tina coming to respect sydney's
skills and now the payoff of that
character arc is what's causing conflict
this is the case for each character and
what i love about this show is that it
illustrates that you don't need these
huge complicated gestures or scenarios
to develop character arcs and motivation
marcus's arc is developed with fairly
minimal screen time because the show is
careful not to waste characters actions
everything they do tells us something
about them and helps us to understand
what motivates their behavior things
we've been rooting for the characters to
do that we're invested in because the
show took the time to develop the
characters interests and motivations are
now blowing up in their faces and it
makes it hard to watch that happen
when it all comes crashing down it does
so not because the characters goals are
at odds with each other they all want to
make good food and for the restaurant to
succeed
it happens because they're trying to fix
the problem in different ways they're
all looking past each other instead of
working together the show doesn't just
have the intensity of sensory overload
the bear is intense because it's
technically proficient at showing
intense things happening to characters
it's made us care about
a movie that uses not cutting to great
dramatic effect is li changdong's korean
masterpiece burning this is one of those
movies that really grabs you and pulls
you in on the first watch but really
unfolds with even greater depth and
complexity as you re-watch it and it's
available right now in the us on mubi my
sponsor for this video movie is an
online streaming cinema that hand picks
a curated collection of films from
around the globe they have the best most
unique selection of independent classic
art house and indie films from all
around the world their library is always
fresh there's a brand new film every day
with an explanation of why you should
check it out mubi is just hands down one
of the best resources right now on the
internet that's making amazing and
unique cinema available to people around
the world you can check it out right now
with your 30-day extended free trial
when you go to movie.com
thomasflight that's mubi.com
thomasflight i definitely recommend
checking out burning or just explore the
amazing library and find something that
looks interesting to you click the link
on the screen right now to get your
extended free trial and thanks again to
mubi for sponsoring this video
[Music]
[Music]